[Music]
fine I'm here with James and Lee thank
you for joining us hi hi yeah yeah
thanks for having us yeah thank you so
headlander came out earlier this week
did and we're gonna play it you're gonna
play it I know this is going to be
complicated
yeah yeah should we start yeah let's
roll right cool so here we are title
screen uh
let's do a new game let's do a new game
so everyone gets into the headlander
Mythos now what what was the inspiration
behind headlander like who came up with
the idea I want to play as a head in in
1970s outer space uh that would be me
um speaking of heads which which one
should we pick do we want the Guthrie
heads the player can choose from uh I
kind of like the old person let's do old
guy yeah he's like he's seen it all
already yeah he's like why are you
waking me up for this
it's true uh well I mean the inspiration
for the game really uh more than
anything else was 1970 science fiction
um you know uh and probably 1970 science
fiction films more than anything else uh
a couple of the high my favorites are
Logan's Run or zardos oh yeah rollerball
those sort of strange films um
Barbarella Barbarella is a good one and
I think that was even late 60s but
spiritually it's 70s if it's in fits in
uh and you know the science fiction in
that um
that era was really Charming for me
because it it it's kind of the dawn of
when technology was really becoming a
thing like it was clear it was going to
like transform human existence in some
way but computers and lasers and things
like that were still kind of new so no
one really like really understand how
they worked or what it would mean so
there's this really like Charming like
naive take on what could go wrong with
you know humankind's future and
technology that I found just super
interesting and kind of funny when you
look back at it even though it's got
kind of subtext or undertones of
something kind of serious and
existential yeah they don't quite make
them I'm like not anymore no I know I
think we think we have settled into like
No One Believes now that you could
defeat the world's most powerful
computer with a logic removal yeah and
uh I don't know I guess we used to be an
equivalent of that now though they're
like looking back in 10 20 years time I
think the equivalent now is someone
hacking into a computer over the phone
can you do that can you hack a computer
with a phone
yeah yeah so what's happening here so
you start off the game with a bit of
mystery in in kind of classic 1970s
science fiction style and you wake up
just as his head on on a ship and um a
voice in your helmet radio who you spend
a lot of the game listening to and
interacting with his name is Earl and
Earl is telling you a few things
and uh yeah and uh so Earl's telling you
uh you know like uh we got to get you
off the ship Methuselah wants to get
hold of you uh and uh he's gonna help
you but you're not really what any of
that means at this point and you try and
talk but then Earl says hey you don't
have any lungs so uh you can't talk
because you're just ahead heads don't
have one so the character is your
character is silent uh I'm gonna play
through this pretty fast because I think
a lot of people have seen the first part
of the game so I'm gonna kind of blow
through it uh but um yeah this thing
shows you the premise of the game though
that you're the head the head can take
off little hidden things for those of
you familiar with the game you start to
see these little characters here in the
foreground there's a bit evidence of a
fight they show up much later in the
game oh wow those characters so you're
still a little bit of there shadowing do
a lot of things uh this is a little
angry vacuum cleaner the electro sucks
uh we tried to add a lot of these little
little things for you to talk to and
interact with you little bits of the
story of the game and just just have a
lot of fun with the kind of surreal
nature of the whole world
um how did you how did you build the
story like you had the you knew that you
wanted to do this era of sort of 1970s
sci-fi like when did the head come in
when did this happen yeah I'm not sure
it was a bunch of things and I think you
know at one point uh you know really
thinking about uh the side swings from
the era I really liked
um that on some level even though it was
completely stupid it also was really
about identity like what does technology
mean like is is this computer really
sentient because it's Advanced enough
and um I just started thinking about
what makes you you what if you are just
ahead are you still you and what if you
could like dock in and take over these
robot bodies what if uh like they're
citizens in this world who uh most of
the people in the world have been had
their bodies or their minds transferred
to robotic imposter buddies and that's
one of the premises of the game so are
they still really alive or yeah
so it was a lot of those like serious
things but I thought but it would be
great to fly around as a head there was
something about like lunar Landing
module uh and um and lasers were another
big part of it too like lasers bouncing
lasers uh you know I love that they
bounce but they don't just stop yeah
lasers of course lasers bounce like that
would be something they do in science
fiction right and leave crazy Trails
crazy Trails uh this is a uh the beer
the mouth of Methuselah
he's got he's only really represented as
a beard through most of the game so we
have this sort of a solid strange beard
uh and at this point where you're trying
to get uh into the door because if you
fly your head up one of the other basic
mechanic is you can't get through doors
open for little heads so you have to uh
and all doors open when you shoot them
with a laser of the correct color so
I've got a red laser and I can shoot a
red door it's hard to get a shot so you
can bounce lasers nice uh and uh use
that to fly through before it closes now
I have to ask with the whole uh the idea
of being ahead and being alive is that
something that that that you would
choose to do like the people in this
world like would you ever say you know
what forget it let's just be ahead does
that like interest you in anyone well I
guess it depends I mean if the choice
was death or being ahead sure are you
sick of your useless human flesh yet
yeah maybe maybe a little bit I'm
starting to get old you know I'm
starting to oh swap it out for a young
guy yeah very younger maybe a different
shape well you know one of the things
that we don't explicitly go into in the
story very much but is is kind of this
element is that uh the motivation for
for people like transferring and there's
a couple of things that Earl and
Methuselah say and some of the citizens
and we've got like hidden data tapes in
the world that talk about that the world
became a pretty hard place to live in
and so citizens uh after the war right
they don't talk about exactly
the ever war is what they call it so the
idea is that the environment was was
toxic or unfriendly enough that
people were motivated to move over to
something that was free from disease or
old age and could actually exist in that
in that environment so that was kind of
like one of the the ideas there was to
wait maybe why some people would choose
that plus plus become a lot of different
colors so you know like there's that as
well gotta look pretty let's talk about
this art like who like what would you
where did your obviously from the 1970s
films and stuff but this beautiful like
I feel like I'm in a disco
like can you talk about the like the art
design and how you sort of developed it
and why you settled on these sort of
like the bright like flashy colors yeah
um you know again a lot of our
inspiration was uh those 1970s itself
and there's a lot of really amazing uh
art and architecture and graphic design
from the air and a lot of them involve
using unusual color schemes and I think
someone might have approached that uh
making a game the 70s by making
everything
you just got upgraded now so now you
have the ability to I guess vacuum
things off so I'm going to
um vacuum off this tube patch here so
one of the things you can do uh but you
can also use this to pull up heads and
this is a major part of the game is is
sucking off heads I love I love pulling
I love pulling other things heads off
it's so satisfying and it's not it's
like gentle decapitation
yeah you're fine you can get a new body
and if you really hate his head you can
track it down and blow okay he's not
fine anymore yeah he's gone yeah oh my
so uh uh so in terms of the in terms of
the color and stuff you know but we're
also like dealing with the idea of um
lots of lasers uh you know we wanted
something that would really make lasers
feel like glowy and we wanted this
analog fill we like to imagine like the
world uh never had digital technology
somehow underneath everything like all
these guys are running on vacuum tubes
and whatnot so yeah so we see those
screens are like huge CRT style yeah
yeah uh screens and so that sort of like
aberration and color bleed and slightly
like blown out color over saturated this
is sort of like a nod to that era and to
like that that idea of analog technology
see I love I love the stuff that like
emulates the 70s and like emulates like
the 80s like why do you think why do you
think we love that so much is it because
everything is just so like cookie now
and this was like a simpler more
beautiful time
maybe you know it's interesting I think
and part of it too is you know this
doesn't really look if you were to
compare it to something from the 70s it
doesn't really look that close to it but
it it kind of is intended to like recall
what you might remember it to be kind of
like and I think that's kind of fun
because it's kind of the same time it's
somewhat familiar but then somewhat
bizarre and some new and I think that
that kind of gives people like a little
bit of a you can even land with these
little vacuum cleaners oh sorry oh yay
you can talk to the vacuum cleaners too
and when they you talk to them they give
you a little different dialogue so if I
talk to them it has another Electro
sucks they'll talk to me uh as if I'm an
electrostux if I land into this a body
and talk to them they'll talk to me like
I'm uh their new sergeant and then
they're sort of chastising me for being
lazy about taking Grime seriously so we
wanted to have this like little hidden
life for all the like little robots and
AI through there that in some ways
they're more human than the human which
is just kind of a joke kind of an ironic
thing um these guys also do have a
little bit of a tactical thing they can
get small doors but they can also um
eject dust and that kind of distracts
them and while they're distracted you
can suck their head off control their
body but if uh once you of course do
that they get a little alerted to you
and they're a little upset so you know
eventually the um
the game has a lot opens up quite a bit
later on but even this early stage you
can pick a couple different paths and
you can kind of go up here and use this
terminal to activate the elevator and
kind of make your way back this way if
you like to want to go fight some more
Shepherds uh that's what the bad guys
would call here or you can kind of um
take this guy and get this little hidden
door here
and go into these tunnels and only the
electro sucks are allowed to get into
because there's like service tunnels so
is there a lot of hidden hidden stuff
like this yeah we do have a lot of
little hidden places that only your head
can get into or different robot bodies
that you can land onto we've got a
another Electro sucks here and he's
sabotaged the central suction system
because they're kind of anti-central
suction there's a little theme where
they're always kind of got posters
everywhere and uh don't don't want to be
automated which is kind of funny they're
fighting the same fight that Humanity
ultimately is but they're just little
robots uh but we do a lot quite a bit of
hidden stuff a lot of little things for
you to find some of it's just goofy fun
stuff uh and some of it is uh leads to
upgrades and other sort of pickups
actually I'm gonna go back and take this
I love all the shapes of the the games
like the there's barely any straight
lines anyway yeah and like pods like egg
pods and you'll see the helmet as a
theme just constantly all over the place
yeah it's like we did put a lot of shape
of this spaceship we did put a lot of
round things in the game that's true
he's a he's a he's definitely a rocket
it's very I like the the roundness it's
very welcoming like straight lines can
sort of feel like cold but I feel like
this is like a warm awesome world that
if I was maybe ahead floating around and
not being attacked by robots I would
really enjoy uh living here well not
there now that it's yeah now that it's
you know been decimated maybe not that
specific place but not that expensive
but it is true there is something
interesting about uh you know I think
70's design is involved with a lot of
warm tones and a lot of organic shapes I
mean part of that was a was a
technological advance in the 70s and 60s
of architecture a lot of poured concrete
and fiberglass fiberglass yeah
the Plastics yeah it's funny because now
plastic seem really tacky because we're
like we want to go back to authentic
materials like wood is metal but they
were kind of a relatively new
technological advance so it'd be like
but it's cooler it's plastic I remember
my grandparents had plastic on their
Furniture one of these like clear
plastic stuff which was a combination of
like weird crappy futurism uh
yeah Plastics
like putting a putting a skin on a couch
no way
yeah so we've made our way uh We've
escaped the ship and Earl is trying to
guide us away and he's found that the
ship that we're on is is kind of homing
in on a secure deck so we're trying to
divert it so we don't get detected or
immediately surrounded so we crashland
into this big spaceship uh or sorry
space station uh and we're gonna spend a
good chunk of the game here and it winds
up opening up and having a lot of
different zones and the player
um it sort of starts out somewhat linear
but then uh it starts to be
progressively more open and players are
allowed to reach reverse for extra
Secrets uh do side missions uh and all
that sort of stuff but at the same time
we didn't want um I think we weren't
really aiming for a like now you got to
run over the whole game to find that one
thing so we try to keep it a little a
little more guided a little more like
you can follow the story and be a little
more casual about that exploration and
only really engage in it if you want to
you don't you don't have to run down
every end of the upgrade tree you don't
have to find everything but if you're
the type of player enjoys that it's it's
there for you
so are there uh I'm assuming there will
be different kinds of enemies in the
space station yeah uh you know in the
the they all um kind of fall into the
umbrella at least most of them do as
what um we call Shepherds which are the
sort of pure robot police force of
Methuselah that he uses to carry out his
uh evil Draconian will because of course
it wouldn't be a 70 science fiction if
if the world wasn't like some sort of
automated World of Tomorrow that had
gone wrong and that's kind of what it is
right and so uh but each of those
Shepherds has a lot of variety in terms
of what they can do and their strength
and their weapons and um and uh yeah so
that opens up that's quite pretty crazy
they do oh wow so we kind of uh we're
kind of in the underbelly of here and so
even though it's a perfect sort of
fiberglass world the idea we were trying
to sell here is that Underneath It All
it's actually kind of an old space
station made of giant transistors and
vacuum tubes and there's a little like
there's something wrong right because
it's like it's the Utopia that's covered
up by something kind of creepy and weird
I love all the little the like the light
bulbs like that's beautiful little
vacuum guys and it's almost like a real
cave fiberglass
so I was picking up some energy there
and that's that's one of the ways that
you can uh upgrade to your helmet
systems eventually and we got our mini
map which is sort of uh you know you can
pull up a bigger map here and you see
our first objective here and uh you know
we wind up having a pretty elaborate
world with a lot of switchbacks and
everything so this um this film's a good
tool for the player to kind of find
where they are and you see the start of
our upgrade tree here is I've got the
use of pink and brown I love the pink
and brown one and orange are very a very
awesome color combination this aren't
used uh that much anymore so we wanted
to use it I don't really see brown
anywhere anymore wow well I mean like
fast games
yeah well Brown's are a different kind
of brown yeah that's right not but not
the nice Brown the shooter Brown shooter
Brown
so I'm gonna apply to these these little
two blades here which are kind of behind
the scenes there's a lot of these in the
game and one of the things you can find
are these little like little upgraded
flowers and your your helmet is designed
to kind of land into a lot of different
terminals so you can land into these
Terminals and you extract certain energy
and the idea is that it's uh it's making
stronger synaptic connections with your
head in the helmet systems right so my
helmet Health has been increasing you
can see a little extra pip got added to
my my helmet health bar there I love
that the universal dock of this world
around your neck yeah yeah
well and you know one of the ideas was
that it's kind of like much like the
Death Star had that one little exhaust
Port that no one figured out was a bad
idea the the world here was all built
around modular Universal pieces because
why would but I don't know if computers
designing the world right and so it just
happens that that standard caliber that
standard uh diameter you can fit your
helmet docking system right like it was
designed to lock into that
um why did you choose the name methusula
uh there's a couple of um ideas there
and one is uh it's a biblical term you
know and it deals with something that's
sort of been alive a long time kind of
endless life and there's also a if you
if you look at transhumanism uh ideas
I'm not a big transhumanism person but
it is the idea of extending your life by
like say uploading yourself to computer
methuselahity is a term that they offer
oh so there's um there's a couple of
connections there that's great it was
usually one of the uh uh wine bottles
side names that's no that's another
thing yeah is there methus I don't think
so there should be it sounds like
outside the standard there's this
mindset being a ton Nebuchadnezzar is
like 25 wine bottles yeah yeah insane
perfect yeah
back to talking about alcohol again yeah
well you know you know we can't stay
away
so we're gonna go into the fun with that
that's the pleasure pour by the way yeah
we're in the pleasure points get some
good names of rooms and here's the
fondularis what's it called apparently
we can see some undulating robots there
on the shag carpet you can also do and
this is also where interesting beads
yeah yeah you can talk to these people
that looks like a very uh a very
comfortable carpet it is and um you know
they're they're enjoying themselves here
this is kind of like they're they're all
these like ridiculous uh pleasurable
activities that don't make sense you can
dance I was gonna ask the last time when
I first time I played I found the dance
button uh like first try yeah it's it's
something we never tell the player
specifically but um having watched some
streams of people a lot of people are
finding them and having fun there's
another dance here nice and you could do
it anywhere in the game and it's uh you
know it's kind of funny because it's
also the melee button for combat bodies
but these citizen bodies uh aren't
combatant so you can um you know but if
you use that same button they do battle
through the medium Donuts that's what
I'm saying can you can you dance battle
uh you can't specifically know but um
that's obviously what that's foreign
have these now this is amazing you
should make a high five Lounge there are
some days when all I need is another
human to just affirm
a firm with a with it with a palm press
everything everything's going great so
we're gonna get a little upgrade here as
well I'm gonna put in a wreck for that
that's the kind of uh San Francisco tech
company higher right go for like we need
somebody to stop go around high-fiving
just because everyone needs like pumping
up so we need some high five
for you oh yeah like you could designate
someone you want to get a high five you
have been high-fived yeah and someone
else would high-fiving for you
sometimes you can hold your iPhone
like an app where like a hand comes up
and it's like good job I do have like an
image you know it's pretty old like jpeg
that's good to send around it just a
picture of a hand says place your hand
to the screen here
there's another character named Mappy
that you can find throughout the game
he's like a little map assistant and he
talks to he's totally super wanting to
be helpful and he's just annoying uh but
you can um like most things in the world
you can pull mappy's head off any kind
of it's a little sad Mappy but you can
dock into his body and when you do that
you can download map his information to
your map system so it pays to vandalize
yeah there's a weird thing here where
gentle decapitation is constantly
rewarded they're just robots so you know
or people who are downloaded to new
bodies you're not really hurting people
you're just uh borrowing them popping
their heads off but Mappy can also dance
like everyone can dance so Mappy can do
his little dance and um one of the
things he's always asking if you'd like
to know more so he says and every dance
has a custom piece of music looking for
it uh this is a good chance to ask about
the soundtrack we were talking about it
earlier before we went live like like
tell me about it it's so it's it sets
the atmosphere so perfectly yeah I'm
really uh I really love our soundtrack
and it it uh we we first of all have a
huge soundtrack it's about 90 minutes uh
our actual soundtrack that you can get
on Steam which is actually not all of
what's in the game so we have quite a
large soundtrack and it was written by
um David Earl who's a San Francisco
musician and always actually in Oakland
he's here local and he um really loves
his parents when we sat down to work to
Taka early on I said well you know it'd
be great if it was just like all
influenced by analog and he's like oh
what about this guy this guy and this
guy Wendy Carlos and Vangelis and all
these people and so he wound up doing a
lot of it on analog since our game is
actually composed and recorded on about
80 analog since so he actually has
that's incredible these old analog
synths and he borrowed some and and uh
so it's really amazing and um we even
did some of our mastering through some
of our recording through uh real real
tape you know a lot of the um sound
effects and sound design for the game
done by um Camden Stoddard our in-house
sound designer he did a lot of use a lot
of those same instruments to do a lot of
our sound effects so uh we even have a
Cylon Wilhelm scream in the game
somewhere that is so
that's one of those many things that
started as a joke that became uh serious
so this part of the game by the way
we've just been sort of like whining our
ways to sort of teaches about navigation
and looking for hidden areas University
there's some doors that we don't have a
red body to open those doors yet that we
can kind of come back to
but we're just gonna kind of um
move forward here and this is largely a
citizen area there's not a lot of combat
here but you all found mid-range zap
station
zap systems which uh later on let you
kind of fast travel through different
areas I was gonna say if you if anyone's
interested in seeing uh more of the
music we have a music video that we made
a song uh it's up on our YouTube channel
that we'll find YouTube channel pretty
easy to find
but we did a launch day stream it's on
our YouTube channel as well he did a
library yeah he's on that talking more
about the instruments used processes
cool
which is cool we are in the hookah
lounge is this a cutscene just a
cutscene because we're uh the shepherds
are now back in town we're in an area of
security so you can see like the
citizens freak out when Laser's gone
they kind of cower around and we don't
really have
um a enemy body right now so we're just
gonna try and get close and pull his
head off its head off and now we have uh
a laser now we can be evil and shoot at
citizens but we don't want to do that we
can try and talk to them but they're
just really panicked now so we're gonna
leave them alone we can come back talk
to them later and we have a cover system
in the game uh which is pretty light
cover system but it does let you uh kind
of plan out your shots a bit if you are
the type of player who likes to be a
little more tactical with your shots you
can do it um it's also very Run and Gun
Style game so it really kind of supports
different play Styles
um but you can switch sides in the cover
and when you go into cover it goes
automatically into precise mode so it's
great for kind of lining up headshots
and you know I can sit here and wait for
these moments and shoot their heads off
nice because your robot bodies don't
heal by themselves so you know
eventually what happens is if you've
taken up damage they'll blow up which is
also a really good strategy because you
can like run it if you're gonna blow up
you can run in some enemies and then
jettison your head and then it'll blow
up you can also do this all the time
anytime you use a zap pad and there's
another person on the target you can uh
telephragm which is fun so you can also
kind of time those in combat they'll
kind of cross those and if you pull one
of those off that's awesome it's like a
nice little it's a nice little touch
there
and so we've got some angry Shepherds
here so I'm gonna shoot these guys and
one of the things that this area
introduces is the idea of a lockdown
room so you sort of Hit the scanner and
the computer is detected that you're not
really a citizen here and so these doors
lock down and they unlock uh in based on
different things uh in this case
um
uh they will they will unlock based on
sometimes it's killing a certain number
of enemies but in this case I'm gonna
have to do something a little bit more
I'm throwing the lasers we can also go
up in melee people which starts out kind
of not super powerful but you can
upgrade that over the course of the game
now you see whenever they take critical
damage they have a few seconds and they
blow up which can take out other enemies
as well so they're kind of like every
enemy is basically like a mobile red
Barrel
I can land in here and deactivate the uh
doors the lockdown's over
um again you can always keep an eye out
for secret Areas like there's another
one hiding up here you find these little
areas sneaky
gonna go in here this soundtrack is like
so good
energy and one of the things you'll see
is sometimes you'll see things like this
like this is a continuous laser beam
that will just blow my head up and I
don't yet have the ability to get past
these but this is one of the upgrades
that you'll get pretty soon
um and we can kind of come back and yeah
you can also it's also pretty fun just
to run your head into things
yeah uh yeah so we also talked about uh
enemies and you see when you land in
this one this guy says Patrol Red Double
and he's got a two icon so he fires two
lasers right on top of each other so
it's almost like a double damage laser
whereas this character here is this got
a single one so you kind of um have to
sort of pay attention there's a little
bit of Discovery from Landing in
different bodies and figuring out which
lasers that you'd like to use
there's a little hidden stuff in the
game is all a little hidden interactions
I can go here and interact with this and
little advertisements are replaced with
propaganda about the Omega gym which is
a sort of a new restraining shift we
have in the game how did you um uh do
the oh we got a uh we got a trophy how
did you I wanna I wanna listen to you if
it's okay to talk to someone
oh yeah the
little dialogue of these guys here we go
so these guys uh they have little bits
of backstory so like the citizens this
is a satellite Chalet so uh these guys
kind of talk a little bit about like the
the uh what this area used to be so this
apparently the satellite Chalet at some
point was the satellite
so now he's talking about how much
better it is that there's no screaming
and there's artificial
screaming anymore
there's a dog there's a dog there's
another dog oh yeah we have dogs do you
talk to dogs
yeah they they pant uh the great thing
about dogs is you can also suck a dog
head off oh which sounds terrible uh and
land into the and if you talk to the dog
they'll bark back and you can talk to
other people and then they'll be like
talk to you as if you're a dog now oh my
gosh so this guy's like I remember the
head's looking that way and uh he's he's
sort of saying unkind things about the
dog's head your head as a player uh
what's the secret secret dog hauls yeah
there are I think it's talk let's find a
secret dog yeah so you can also bark as
I log and do a little bit of damage to
people it's pretty small amount of
damage but they get a little upset
um you uh so the thing about dogs is
because they're also these little tiny
guys you can um run them into those
little small doors that are meant
actually for the vacuum cleaning systems
of the station but because they're small
they they'll get into there as well so
you can kind of kind of sneak in there
so we'll take we can take this little
guy oh this is the best this is the best
adventure we're a dog we're a dog so
we're in here this little Electro sex
hatch now we can't get that upgrade now
because again we've hit something and we
can't quite pass yet but we come back to
it you can also see there's some
propaganda posters there's say no to
centralizing propaganda poster on the
wall like Electro sex have a little
hidden propaganda things in their um in
their little areas all of the graphics
propaganda and advertising stuff it's so
awesome there's like every room has its
own logo almost yeah yeah we we had to
localize we went to localize on these
things these things are you know custom
logos and textures I think we had like
280 logos we had to oh my god
um the artist all hated me yeah for that
there's weird things to localize as well
like oh my gosh yeah they're strong
Delirious yeah
what is it I don't remember just I just
remember it looking great I want to know
Snowman
so you can there's a little hidden
things that you can find and they give
you little bits of energy to reward
exploration but you can also land in
them and this is Frosty The Observer
it's a little backstory like maybe
Peter's always watching people but you
can then dance he's got a little dance
too
get a little reward for dancing we've
got a lot of different dances in
different areas of the game um the dog
the interesting about the dog is is I
don't have
upgrade right now but let's see we can
upgrade our melee or I can save it let's
see
um so the way way upgrades worked is you
can you get these Branch ones at certain
key points in the game but you have all
these optional upgrades so if I want to
like increase the melee power I can buy
that now I have two further nodes I
could upgrade or I could say points and
increase my suck power uh or I could do
this what's called a headbutt takeover
looks like you head butt people and
knock their head off and swap yours on
too so it's like that sounds awesome
the dog actually you can actually use
them for combat eventually like if some
of the upgrades if you apply to the dog
you actually have this thing that's hard
for Shepherds to hit and you can
actually take them out I don't have
those upgrades right now but it's pretty
funny to um I'm actually gonna go you
see that there's a red door here we
don't have a Shepherd goodbye dog body
and the bodies just stay there like
after they do yeah and actually their
head stay here too and uh you can have
fun just playing with heads throwing
them around they make very satisfying
sounds but you can also later on you can
do things like push energy into the head
and turn it into a bomb and throw it so
they also have a you know like a
tactical thing you can do with them as
well this is just having fun so we're
gonna go this way and there's a red door
I can't open
um oh they're coming at so yeah all of
our our doors our door systems run by a
sarcastic door Ai and if you try and
access color systems uh they just make a
lot of color puns so uh he's just trying
to tell you need bread but anyway so
they're really terrible color punches is
a lot of them it's a few hundred line
color lines yeah
that was Mike laprete it was a foodian
uh so we can go this way and this leads
us to another upgrade station and what
this is going to do this is going to
give us another one of those branch
level upgrades
and we're gonna get the ability to get
through some of those lasers that we've
been seeing so all of our upgrades kind
of have a traversal navigation function
like maybe let you get in areas we also
have a combat function and sometimes
just a goofy humorous function so in
this case we couldn't get past these but
now I have this little bounce Shield but
I can pull out one of my head and I can
rotate it around with my right
thumbstick while flying and so I can go
through things like that and reflect it
um and now that I'm through there for
example I just hold this thing off and
deactivate those lasers and I can take
my body through you'll also notice I now
have a new pink meter that's my energy
so as you use certain abilities uh
upgrades and stuff they'll use energy
and so in the case of the bounce Shield
it doesn't use any energy to have out
but the more shots I take it'll start to
drain energy so you can see up here this
guy will shoot at me I can use this
thing
I can use this thing to bounce his shots
back oh man you see my shield drain
because you hit it a number of times
he's got a double laser so it doesn't
doesn't take too long I know there's a
little hidden thing here I can land into
this deer head oh I died
now you your energy automatically
replenishes you don't have to like
collect it it does yeah it's it's a um
so it um yeah the energy is uh it's sort
of like you can think of it kind of like
a shield your head health yeah and this
and the head energy work the same way
where they'll both like drain and then
recharge over time you can also upgrade
that head power a lot over the course of
the game through other pickups So
eventually you can get some really
powerful things that take a lot of
energy and that really helps the game so
you can take a lot more shots in this
case to your bound Shield I miss the dog
I know and there's gonna be another
little place we could take the dog right
there there's Mappy again trying to be
helpful mappy's also got a lot of cute
things so if you like punch Mappy he's
like assuming that you're trying to like
hug him and he's like see he just likes
to be home Mappy has no arms you with
yeah you see there's a little hole down
there
mappy's got some comments about being
shot too see he's like but you can also
yeah
now he's actually kind of tough so if
you ever need to get through an area
sometimes so you can take a lot of shots
he's built to last but you take his head
off uh mappy's actually voiced by
Richard horvitz who's the voice of Razz
and psych nuts wow a little hidden thing
there so uh this guy has now rebuilt a
whole lot of stuff thanks Mappy yeah so
we're supposed to be like realigning all
these satellites here and um the way
most of our objectives work is that you
kind of get into an area and somewhat of
a guided path but once you're in that
area you can kind of approach this
objective in any order you wish and um
that kind of creates a lot of different
experiences with people like I didn't
have to get the upgrade then I could
have gone a completely different way
oh yeah this is what we found last time
there was a little hidden thing here you
can sometimes you can use the creepy
deer head yeah so the creepy deer head
also named Buckshot uh fires like these
things I kind of cleared the enemies out
but uh we can Buckshot him to death too
so that's awesome uh so this is a place
here where you go like paddle and this
is kind of like I wouldn't say our game
is it's puzzly but not in sort of an
adventure game when it's a lot of
traversal it's like well how do I get
into that as a head well what you can do
is you can fire a laser and before it
closes you can go over here and fly
through or I can sit there and let this
guy shoot at me and his laser opened the
door for me and can fly through so we
have a lot of those type of things where
there's really multiple ways to get
through our bound Shield helps here
because we can kind of reflect our
lasers back and blow them up we could
just uh you know we could try and Dodge
him it was pretty easy to dodge at this
stage of the game
um but it's fun to blow this girl fun to
blow things up these guys
and there's energy here and then you
could do like hey those little testing
things let's just blow those up
everything
a colorful explosions see there's
another one down here isn't there so
we'll just found some lasers and try and
take them right off here it goes uh yeah
some long stuff this one so here's
another case where we can't really get
through it before but now that we have
our bound shield and kind of get through
find some more hidden stuff so you see
them in the small area of the game we
got a little passages
um this will give me more upgrade points
these little energy tubes let's see I've
got a couple here so I can go here and
uh I can see now that we've unlocked
Mount Shield I have a whole new branch
of stuff so now I can kind of give my
body more armor so this means any body
I'm docked into can take more damage
which is useful I can get body
regeneration which lets bodies heal over
time which until this point you don't
have any way to keep the bodies from
blowing up all the time this one gives
you a double mirrored Shield eventually
you get to these sort of hidden ones on
the end here you can see there's a half
circle where you have to connect both
branches to be able to buy that upgrade
but let's take audio armor body armor
I love switching switching bodies so
often yeah that's not my problem
not my body not my problem
and that is kind of a great close-up but
it is kind of it's kind of a strange
thing in the game because you're used as
players in this game like trying to
really hold on to your bodies but but
bodies are really disposable in this
game in a lot of ways and so like I'm
gonna let this guy shoot me here for a
minute I give myself body armor which
makes me even more durable but when
things that happens you see I take
critical damage here my body will start
flashing and I can run oh I blew that of
course when you can you get like five
seconds where your body really blows up
and you can do things like run it near
the enemy who's trying to shoot you and
let it blow them up which is pretty fun
so I found a um one of the things I'm
supposed to do here is tune these
satellites so I'm gonna kind of go
through it pretty quickly but there's a
lot of hidden songs and backstory to
find in these places
I can't actually hear which ones are
right so I'm like it is quick
but what we're trying to do here is is
clear up the signal so that Earl of the
guy who's been helping you in your
helmet radio can
connect with you and help guide you to
the next area because he's getting
connected
I love that you physically move that
stuff yeah yeah it's that analog thing
right take some cover here he's blown up
just like dialing a radio right here in
your car into a different thing it's a
physically
here's a case where I'm gonna let my
body oh yeah nice I ejected out of the
body as it was about to blow up and then
its explosion took the enemy out for me
but now I can't get through here because
I don't have a laser right so you might
feel like how are we trapped no you know
what you need to do that
uh and so you you know there's a lot of
different ways you could handle that but
um this we're gonna handle the easy way
which we're gonna do a little fall keep
here we'll just run through here oh boy
but we got enemy waiting for us
so we'll take out my balance Shield it's
a little tricky to reflect the shots
back into them we're going to make that
too easy but it is enough to protect you
and every once in a while you pull off
like you make them shoot their own head
off and that's really satisfying
[Music]
oh so I'm blowing up now but I launched
my body and took him out
[Music]
uh no not really you know this whole
thing is called the satellite Chalet uh
which we just sort of like there was
something about like A-frame ski lodges
in the 70s that Were Somehow big
yeah there's a there's a ski lift uh
yeah
just snowfall you can sort of see how
it's it's kind of like the you know one
of the ideas here is that the computer
with you just doesn't really understand
Humanity even though it's supposed to be
the most advanced computer in some ways
it's the least human released
so it does all these things that are
kind of like well hey humans you know
humans want like um a satellite so they
want to chill here this is a relaxing
place but then it's filled with like
security monitors and uh robots doesn't
get it because I couldn't understand
it's a limitation
so this one has a shield and we can't
we're supposed to get in here and try to
manipulate this terminal but we've got
this cycle left field so we have to find
a way to take that one down
what's all the appetizing
or something it's a yeah
is pretty
excuse me I'm aware of these things
cultural references
yeah zebra government like it's like it
was an in thing like you had you had to
be in the know
you had to pee in the know
unusual
no it was crazy it was white gum with
like rainbow stripes on it and they were
all like different flavors and the packs
would come with like 50 like 50 pieces
of it yeah and it was good all I feel
was just that it looked cool like I
don't think it tasted very good oh and
it came with the temporary
it was all tattoos tattoos mascot which
is like a zebra and sunglasses it's got
a little healing station here you can
find it periodically if you want to kill
the body move that's a very elaborate
healing yeah it's kind of a giant they
found a little uh
let's keep right here this one's a
little more laser heavy so if you
haven't hadn't found your upgrade here
you probably wouldn't be able to get to
this area but I can go here and get some
more update points
nice oops all right oh so that's what
happens sometimes your angle is off and
yeah I remember in development that
angles
yeah well it's no it's good it's yeah
yeah it's like you try to try to try to
get the you know so there's some Masters
or some like um skill you develop over
time with it right but you don't want it
to be unpredictable just like trying to
get that balance just right here how
long uh how long was headliner in
development well
um we've been like kind of in full
development since let's see was it
December of 2014 so it's about 16 months
I'd say I think that was
that's true
yeah
you know of our Amnesia Fortnight I do
Atlanta was one of the one of the games
from
2012.
anyways oh so there's an example and
wasn't voted on to be made and then it
was Revisited late afternoon nice yeah
we're actually making the game with
Adult Swim you know yeah who uh has been
it's like a really perfect partner for
such a strange game uh you know we
[Laughter]
they're all awesome actually like really
fun to work with yeah they really got
headliner they really understood the
weird stuff that was just eager to put
in the strange thing which is fantastic
you were just like your head in space
floating around terrorizing a space
station causing mass destruction
so what we thought was our first orange
Shepherd we've been here so we one thing
we haven't really talked about is the
shepherd colors you see the lower right
with a security bar there and it's like
those red orange yellow green blue
violet and each each uh Shepherd that
you get into has a color and that
determines the doors of the only so you
have an orange door here and it also
determines like how many times our
lasers bounce this orange laser will
bounce a little hard to show up here see
it bounces twice now instead of once uh
and then a yellow guy will bounce three
times in a green Ford of blue five and
so it gets crazier but we can also open
up these doors now as an orange guy but
they're also um a little tougher like
the you can take a few more shots and
they do a little more melee damage and
their lasers do more damage so it's kind
of like that when you fight the tougher
enemies there are also the weapons
you're going to be using so it's kind of
an unusual Dynamic where you you know I
could just run a gun and blow these guys
up really quickly but then if they
actually happen to have a body I want I
have to be a little more careful yeah
and find a way to like take their heads
out either by doing a headshot or at
this stage I could you know go here and
pull it off the vacuum Drive there's
other upgrades that you can use to get
onto the heads as well the head went
rolling you can see I don't yeah I threw
it all up bye punch his body goodbye
forever
yeah I don't have much health left in
this character so like if I if I bring
wanted to hold onto this body I could
try and find a way to get it to a health
station uh you know I know this one
right there but I'm gonna not do that
there's an intriguing question find
another sweet box
oh my she was having none of it so these
guys can kind of mow these red guys down
here and I'm gonna go in here which was
an orange door I needed to get from oh
it's another
thing there's a thing oh no I'm gonna
lose body if I lost it but I made it
into the orange room
I love that the heads just like bounce
and roll away and it's like that's it
yeah I'm Gonna Save that orange body
they're fine they probably download it
somewhere
but the human is the citizens they uh
there's a little story point where they
talk about how they get redownloaded to
a new body if anything goes wrong so the
funny part in the game is that if you
look closely when you land to a citizen
body you'll see a name like John
and the thing is if you actually kill
that person blow up their body not
really killing them uh and you come back
later into that same room last time they
will be incremented so it'll be like
johnny-11
y'all skipped
which is another story Point yeah
there's uh that's sort of the rebels
later on you meet are the daughters of
Lucia 13 and that the computer believes
that uh bodies with a 13 designation are
um have inherent flaws because the
rebels uh the first Rebel was 13. so
there's all this like this guy's own
Superstar he's on the Superstition yeah
not substantiated by anything but so
there's no 13 in anybody
I read a Thing Once about some people
who programmed a robot to bid on the
stock market based and to develop its
own superstitions based on what it is
found what happened it wasted all this
money
you know like it would take all human
superstitions like
that's bad whatever then it would like
letters on Wednesday and the weather was
a certain way of developing oh my God I
did that twice and and that's bad I'll
never do that again crazy that's funny
so that's how I imagine with this I
guess it's just purely statistic based
superstition
having fun I forgot to actually uh tune
the satellite having fun having fun too
much fun blowing up things
so you have all the colors
oh yeah so well you know when uh they're
there's as far as I know people still
debate whether there's actually indigo
is a separate color and so uh yeah
there's no Indigo the Methuselah decided
to go like indigo's [__] it's just
blue and violet so yeah there's there's
no Indigo there is I think there's a few
jokes in there somewhere in the game I'm
sure I wrote some stupid jokes about
your videos
it's like you know deciding food is on
the planet and it goes yeah color that's
true
I'm trying to think of the last time I
saw like an actual rainbow rainbow and
like I mean it's a carton it doesn't
rain enough here no yeah exactly like
the last rainbow we saw was like across
the country
so we're just too dry and got a quad
split level rainbows exactly
yeah
they don't have Indigo I think oh yeah
they just do stop it perfect
I need to um yeah right now my upgrades
don't my melee is not doing too much
damage but if you upgrade it all the way
you basically can one hit punch kill
people which is pretty fun uh it's
almost there I'm gonna still wow so I
have a quad split laser oh which is
pretty crazy oh my God I'm nuts with it
oh he got me but I'm gonna use my body
to blow up his body and now I'm gonna
wait for one to respond and take his
head before he can hurt me so will they
always respond like if you just stand
there uh no no it's it's it's it's you
know it it's uh and this guy has a try
so this is three shots of orange power
right on top of each other this is a lot
of damage uh but in terms of body
respawning uh we have people running
from doors uh if you're ever left alone
in a room for a long time since you need
a body to get out we find a way to get a
body in there but it's not always the
same place it's not always the same time
so there's some Randomness there and you
can't just completely predict it you
know uh so I like that the orange the
orange robots kind of have these like
short shorts like a short short thing
going on yeah uh well you know what it
is it's funny is we actually have even
though they have no no uh genders per se
we actually have the shepherds are
slightly feminized and slightly
masculine in different models so this
one is slightly the feminine and the
voice is slightly uh different uh and
just because we thought it'd be
interesting if they even they had some
slightly more human attributes there's
no reason that methusel would give them
just one of those sort of insane things
oh my losing my cool body
can get up here
so many lasers there you go
yeah it um you know when you're at the
earlier levels of the game like this uh
because one thing Superman has put a ton
of lasers on the screen a lot of times
lasers just wind up being like you can't
do that much with lasers because it
would just kill people all the time but
since bodies are disposable kind of in
this awesome we can kind of put a ton of
lasers on screen because you still have
you can inject it as a head and you're
kind of more vulnerable as a head but
you're also in some ways harder to hit
so it's like this interesting balance
where like let's put a ton of lasers a
lot of people lose bodies all the time
um and that I think gives the game a
unique feel that it's hard to do unless
you're maybe playing like a shmup or
something you know where it's just like
tons of lasers everywhere and I'm
getting caught like a fool trying to get
through here no what's in here I want to
get the bonus all right so we've
realigned all five of the satellites and
Earl's like I can talk to y'all now so
you need to go to the power Dome
[Music]
you can see we've kind of like this is
where we've got so far we've got a
waypoint down here now we could so far
go back uh at any time and hit some of
these like we've even some here that
aren't in the map that we haven't found
there's also a side quest or two that
we've passed at this point
um that we could come back to but I'm
just going to kind of move through some
of the areas
[Laughter]
it's pretty easy to get through you
pretty much just press straight up
you're such a nice explosion of color
Yes
all right guys we're let's see
so we've got an orange body and this
looks kind of like where we're gonna go
so I'm gonna try and get down to that
part there uh and I need an orange body
to get to that door
I'm a [__]
it's like you've been playing this for a
while a little bit
okay so we're gonna go down
we had access
yeah built in case
you gotta run power conduit somewhere
it's the future so now I found myself a
yellow body and the yellow try this
thing is gonna do a serious amount of
damage if we find anything less than
yellow it has pretty much no chance it's
like this guy goodbye wow uh yellow is
so Opie yes you can see the tower Bernie
halfway up that color scale
yeah and there's many different types of
weapons that we have fractal lasers that
show up later that that fire in fractal
patterns that put like 30 lasers on the
screen wow
Popeye yeah uh so there's definitely
it's an interesting power curve you
don't always notice it because sometimes
you tend to fight you know in areas
you'll get in areas where maybe there's
a lot of other yellow people as well but
you know you find some of the other
things some of the less power guys
pretty overpowered
this place
more robots
for a head he uh
runs pretty well he does yeah he's got
that Locomotion down well you know it
doesn't get tired you just need to get
tired those guys every time you get
tired you could just switch out oh look
at that now I'm just sweating oh yeah
that's a bound shot because yeah now
this thing is bouncing an additional
time from from Orange right so I'm
bouncing because uh like three times now
uh there's a little yellow door up here
so this one is a Repair Station you see
I've taken some damage and I really like
this yellow body so I don't want to lose
it so there's another fresh one yeah
there's a fresh one there but let's see
if it's laser is better because I have a
triple this looks like this is a triple
as well so we're pretty good oh and a
little secret pick up a fresh bod be on
your way yeah it's windy story picked up
a six-pack it sounded weird I don't yeah
there is a lot of body
see that we have another upgrade this
should maybe let me upgrade my melee all
the way
and I can start to do something else a
little crazy and see what we have for
upgrades at this point it looks like it
almost looks like the Death Star in
these little sections just like all the
lights going up the side yes okay so
let's try a headbutt takeover so let's
do it so this one um that's true that is
very Death Star all the little square
yes and it is very Darth Vader Star Wars
was actually 70 science fiction although
we did look at Star Wars 2 which just
because it's so ubiquitous but we did
look a lot at um other things Ralph
McCory who's the sort of Chief
production designer did like Battlestar
Galactica
so um I can show you uh let's see let's
[__] everybody uh before we go out let's
show us one more cool thing okay uh
let's how about we take over someone's
head or body with my head let's do it
let's head
body
and there we go that's also convenient
even if you have bodies you just want to
switch like oh that one's on level hey
you yeah you do have to get close to
them so it is a little harder if they're
firing lasers at you uh to actually make
it there but also since I've upgrade my
melee it's just like a one-hit headbutt
swap but if you hadn't done that it
would take a couple of headbutts uh so
yeah that's pretty fun to do if you
could give the people that are picking
up headlander this week one piece of
gameplay advice both of you please one
thing you can only tell them one thing
one piece of guidance
um
my one piece of guys my one piece of
guidance would be
um
to ah geez I don't know what did I say I
would say just have fun with it because
we we tried to design a lot of the
different branches all to be successful
so that you wouldn't like optionally
paint yourself in a corner but really to
kind of look at those upgrades and if
you're a person who likes to fly around
and like shoot em ups and like to be
just the head there's upgrade options
that let the head become an offensive
weapon but if you're like more like I
like to say cover and I really like
bouncing lasers then kind of upgrade
those systems and um hopefully people
find a whole upgrade path that's just
for the way that they like to play the
game but try them all out because
sometimes they don't you're not sure of
like is it that fun to head butt someone
and the answer is yes it is yeah that
looks really fun what about you you can
even head by the citizen I would say if
you're a fan of double fine games in
particular or maybe if you're not just
spend time like just looking at all the
silly background things talking to
people because there's some really
stupid dialogue and funny jokes and
crazy puns Leah's got a crazy dirty pun
mind and uh I've seen so much stuff very
good before you define and just really
enjoy the
you know the style and the presentation
of this thing awesome well thank you so
much for coming by and showing this a
headlander yeah any anytime you guys are
right down the road just come over and
hang out
well headlander out this week PC and PS4
correct it came out on Tuesday and you
can see our review up on gamespot.com
thanks everyone
foreign
[Music]